you've made so many
great
shows and movies
um in your career so many that we've
enjoyed so much and i watched likewise
oh thank you well i watched your new
show severance
oh cool i mean
what'd you think
it's so first of all it's directed by
ben stiller yeah i'm i'm loving watching
it tell us about it well thank you i'm
so glad you like it um yeah you know ben
you know what a
brilliant guy he is and he
yeah he had this vision and dan erickson
who created the show as well
ben kind of took it and came up with the
whole visual language for
this world it really was world building
because there's this whole you know
science fiction and so you have to
introduce the audience to this all these
circumstances in this whole it's a world
of this company and this technology the
the show takes place in a world where
you can have a chip inserted in your
brain so when you go to work you take an
elevator down to the office and on that
elevator ride the chip is triggered so
when you're down there you have no idea
who you are in the outside world you
have no access to those memories your
entire life and world is there at work
and then when you leave work at the end
of the day it's triggered again and
you're in the outside world but have no
memory of what you did at work that day
so you have these two separate wild
i mean
yeah it's really cool it's a cool idea
it's really fun i was i really i knew
that going in um and it didn't ruin it
for me it helped it and i loved it yeah
sure
what an incredible premise for
life a show a debate
i it's so rich really
[Music]